[Music]
we have great fans sometimes they come
to our show holding signs or wearing
funny outfits during this monologue
during the monologue I noticed this guy
Billy can you cut to the gentleman over
there that's the guy he's holding a sign
that says bring back wink oh I'm sorry I
have to say I have no idea what that
means sir what's an oink oh my god the
Boyko he's my favorite character from
you chef I'm sorry disappoint you we've
been a ton of characters on our show but
there's never ever been a character
named in Co the blink Oh
okarin sure there has don't tell me you
forgot about Orko the Blanco the giant
pig who boinks people with his
inflatable mallet all right I haven't
forgotten about you Eko cuz there never
was an oink-oink Allah Blanco is one of
the greatest coding characters of all
time sir I am I would have remembered a
character named uncle the boink Oh Andi
am i missing something here no Conan
you're right I mean I don't remember a
character named oink oh maybe he's just
miss remembering a few the kangaroo the
profane kangaroo with a power drill
remember that I think we have a picture
oh yeah yeah yeah all right I remember
after you the kangaroo sir what is it
you're thinking of don't get me wrong I
loved it when Fu the kangaroo would
drill holes in your desk while sang
profanities it was always hilarious but
he doesn't compare to all week oh he's
right Conan were uncle maniacs too oh
boy are we ever remember winco's theme
song oh boy go
oh boy go oh my god go with a oink oink
why can't a point blank blank an alike
boink boink and a boy going like an
annoyed boy i got a boy boy boy one more
time no stop it stop it I don't remember
that theme song because it was never on
our show you know what let's just sell
this once and for all why don't we just
ask him
oink Oh have you ever been on the show
before nope this is my first appearance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is like the sketch that we would do
if we were faking faking being a sketch
house as a cover for our now we're a
real show this is called the writer's
back last week it's real quiet on the
lot you sitting around sounds me that's
feeling real giddy like Andre I bought a
pig costume on the bridge oh it sounds
like he wants to write it off oh man
well right okay there's an expense that
was just like how many people can we get
in the crowd who are fake
talking about something that never
happened oh boy
[Laughter]
huh just roll out Andres crowd I don't
know what to say I love you Andre
I really do you gonna try stuff it would
be kind of fun to see boy go come down
like completely nonplussed on entertain
people they're just a bunch of advanced
to flat faces being like file this one
away first level of indulgence for a bit
yeah scraps - scraps of scraps to fill
around scraps on YouTube extra YouTube
Junior
[Music]
you